They are tender, intelligent and very affectionate,
that is to say, expensive to keep my
dogs, they receive a haircut every
six weeks, the brushes constantly
even if I do not want to, but in the end it is
worth it, honestly, it is an investment as
if it were a child, they are not cheap and if you
find one  At a low cost, it
is possibly a scam.
Every day the popularity
of the sub-breed dogs grows, which are
dogs of the poodle breed crossed with
another breed, so they come in a
variety of sizes and colors, one of their
most notable characteristics is that  they are
super affectionate my dog lies down next
o me but he settles in me as if he were a bab
he is very tender my dogs mean
verything to me the a
pearance of each tough barea and another of th
characteristics that makes them one of th
most desired breeds is  their shaggy
curly hair and my main reason is that they
don't shed as much when i researched
the breed of dog they are and that they don't
shed i decided it would be the
id pet  eal for our family to
know the authenticity of each breed you have
to know how the
mix of breeds and their embers are cataloged as well as
the generations of these dogs for
example if you cross a golden retriever
with a poodle or pure it will result in a
hard  category type f1 now if you
cross that same golden duro with another
poodle it will result in a type
efe 2 b and so on we got our
duro thanks to the funds we received
at our wedding everyone helped us
buy it and now I don't think I have any other
dog
bailey era  a second generation enduro goal
or f1 v he was a
fun and healthy pet but also the source
of many headaches
felix always attended his
vet visits and was of exemplary
behavior we never had any cause for
concern about his health everything took a
turn  unexpected when one night
bailey woke up from his nap
completely disoriented it
was a long and sad night for
us and at the same time difficult  Because we
didn't know what was happening to him
, he suddenly had trouble walking,
he lost his sight and his balance
until his symptoms escalated to
vomiting and seizures after
several visits to the emergency room
and countless medical tests with
much  pain
we had to say goodbye to our
dear bailey it was difficult to lose him and
even more to assimilate that a puppy
just over a year old had such serious and
incurable health problems and it is
difficult as humans not to have all the
answers doctor jessica jensen is a veterinarian
with endy  speakers she says that despite
the fact that mixed breeds are healthier
there are always diseases the most
common are problems with their hips
bone diseases and being overweight
but most of these can be treated
in health insurance it is very important
for pets because they will always have
unexpected emergencies medical costs
are high and add up very
quickly
the doctor tells us that the s  Medical insurance
for pets includes specific
policies that you should be
aware of, among them it covers
different visits to the emergency room and preventive treatments,
so it is important to know
before choosing it in Bailey's case,
despite having medical insurance, her health
could not extend the increase  there is a
growing community of dog owners
in las vegas' and they are quite united and
even have several groups on facebook
our family on the dog page on
facebook is very united we help each other with
advice questions and we even organize
weekly meetings so that the dogs
can  playing is so much fun